Hey, David, why is the United States Northeast
and New England so liberal if it started with
conservative pilgrims? This is a great question.
What you have to understand is that today,
if we think back to the pilgrims, they are
extremely conservative by today's standards.
A Bernie Sanders progressive from Boston today
is way to the left of a pilgrim that was in
modern day at what is now Boston a hundreds
of years ago. Okay. But at the time they were
progressive given what they were doing. We
talked about this in our, our video called,
uh, I think it's called the founding fathers
were progressive and you should be too, or
something like that.
Fighting the powers of England to separate
and become independent with the idea of freedom
of and freedom from religion, even though
they were religious at the time, was a radical,
progressive forward thinking idea at any particular
point, what you have to understand is the
people in the northeast of the United States,
we're the progressive's relative to whatever
group they were separating from or whatever
the alternative effectively was. Yes. To me
today in 2019 as you know, culturally Jewish
left the millennial, David pacman pilgrims
seem outrageously conservative to me, but
compared to the establishment status quo people
that they were separating from at the time
they were progressive left wingers. As you
move forward in time, as Evangelical Christians
started to spread to different parts of the
United States, the northeast is almost not
at all evangelical evangelicals are one of
the most conservative branches of Christianity.
Instead in the northeast, you've got Catholics
and Quakers and Unitarians and other sects
and probably I would argue, although I haven't
looked at the numbers more Jews, I mean Massachusetts
in New York, I know have more Jews than most
of the u s but maybe some of these other northeast
New England states do as well.
Jews, one of the most liberal voting groups
groups in the country. Uh, when you look at
that, you realize, oh yeah, at any given time
you also had fewer of the most conservative
religious sects in the northeast relative
to the Midwest and the south with evangelicals
and other more conservative Christian groups.
But there's even more than religion as well
because the history of education also plays
a big role in this. If we zoom out, we know
that when people are less religious and more
educated, they tend to be further progressive.
They tend to be further to the left. When
you look at the history of education and the
preponderance of great colleges in the northeast,
in Massachusetts, in other states, in New
England, that tends to lead to more democratic
voting individuals. Even though you have states
like New Hampshire and Vermont and Massachusetts
that have rural areas that you might associate
more with the Midwest and the south and parts
that tend to have more conservatives.
Um, overall you still have, you know, even
the rural areas in Massachusetts are closer
to urban areas or semi urban areas. They're
closer to other towns. They are often college
towns, which is a significant left leftward
pushing force. Um, and then the other thing
is also the distribution of the Republicans
in the northeast. You still have plenty of
Republicans in the northeast. I mean, I think
even here in Massachusetts, Trump got close
to 40% of the vote, which is, I get it. It's
still, it ended up being more than a 20 point,
uh, margin for Hillary Clinton. But almost
40% of one of the bluest states still voted
for Donald Trump. The thing is they're sort
of sparsely distributed so that they have
a lesser electoral impact. So if I had to
summarize it really succinctly, the reason
why the northeast continues to be a very progressive
part of the country would be more education,
less religion.
And, uh, some of the other kind of geographical
dynamics that tend to appeal more to and be
more common in more progressive rather than
conservative areas.